o une entrée en fanfare pour inaugurer
un terrain de foot cela se passe au ps
où joie et pour ce terrain la
municipalité a choisi un parrain sportif
de référence
dominique rocheteau ancien joueur
vedette de l'équipe de saint-etienne et
ancien joueur du psg qui connaît donc
les élus et que les jeunes question
après marco mais je crois qu'on surnomme
l'ange vert pourquoi est ce qu'on lui
donne ce nom ce que tu sais pas mais ce
qu'il a joué à beaucoup d'équipés avec
un maillot vert saint-etienne dominique
rocheteau inaugure le troisième stade
qui porte son nom en france l'occasion
pour lui de rappeler les valeurs auquel
il est attaché au moins les vraies
valeurs du sport sont éternelles il faut
toujours mais mais c'est un travail de
tous les jours et pour les voilà pour
les pour les véhiculer à travers les
travaux les différentes générations
alors de solidarité moi j'aime bien le
mot solidarité générosité
voilà don de soi ce terrain de football
permettra de recevoir des joueurs toute
l'année des clubs de sport comme des
enfants des écoles pour accueillir les
séances d'entraînement et les matchs
officiels
une première étape dans la reconquête
urbanistique du quartier de l'avre cet
état de l'engagement que nous avions
pris que la commune avait pris et qui
s'inscrit dans la rénovation de tout ce
quartier avec la reconstruction d'une
école qui avait brûlé qu'avait laissé
des traumatismes et puis également donc
avec la création d'une aire de jeux aux
alentours une réflexion d abord
l'équipement a coûté 1 million d'euros
financé à hauteur de 30 mille euros par
la fédération française de football et
160000 euros par le conseil général le
reste à la charge de la commune